a fox news alert he's going after
nuclear power plants leveling
neighborhoods and maybe targeting
civilians intentionally so is vladimir
putin's strategy to take over kiev
changing
joining me now to break it all down as
fox and friends weekend co-host and
afghanistan war veteran pete hegg said
uh pete thanks for your time can you
give us an update what's going on with
this changing strategy it appears he's
gotten um
he's gotten bogged down up north but i
watched this morning on fox and friends
you seem to indicate from the east and
the south he's doing a lot better
that's exactly right i think we have a
time lapse map that's going to show
the fact that the initial push no doubt
the main effort the hope was they were
going to come from the north and they
have been bogged down there uh the
famous 40 mile convoy is a portion of it
it's not just that as a result you but
it was always a four-pronged approach
from the north uh the northeast the east
and the south it turns out they've made
far more advances in the south which is
not advantageous for vladimir putin but
may lead to a shift in strategy and a
tragic one dan because what they have an
advantage of in the south and i think
the next slide shows is that is it's the
closest proximity to the nuclear power
plants one of which they've already
taken over another of which they may
soon take over which means they have
control over whether the lights are on
the power is on the water is on the
internet is on and that and that leads
to the siege mentality when you watch
those time shift map stand it's almost
like an anaconda it's it's a strangle
effect on the country choking off all of
its options except for the west where
they reinforce and of course those those
stingers and those javelin missiles have
been devastatingly effective reports
show that you know it's one man with a
javelin from two and a half miles away
fire and forget can take out a tank and
repeat rinse and repeat and that's very
dangerous for vladimir putin so the
nuclear reactors in the south are being
targeted and that leads me to kind of
the next phase which is civilian
targeting dan i i you know
zielinski the president of ukraine
damned if you do damned if you don't for
him because he knew that he had to ask
civilians to be armed they don't even
have enough weapons for all the
civilians but they're providing them
through the lens of of of vladimir
putin's eyes and again through his lens
he'll say well if you're arming civilian
civilians are targets and when civilians
are armed and there are targets then
civilian buildings are targets and if if
the men and the women and children are
fleeing and if they've left behind then
a woman or a child is a human shield to
a civilian target which he will use to
attempt to rationalize to the rest of
the world why he's hitting civilian
targets and that's a more traditional
russian tactic dan in the south is bomb
and bomb and bomb into submission level
entire cities try to break the will of
the people there and then take not even
take them dan they don't want to hold
this ground they want to put enough
pressure and in inflict enough suffering
that zilinski says our will is broken we
can't fight any longer uh and and that
seems to be the approach that he's
taking we see it in the south and what
he's doing to maripole what he's doing
to kharkiv in the north northeast kiev
is the eventual goal the question is how
much will he extract but but but it's
been really your previous guests were
very interesting i mean they are not
executing the kind of plan they hoped
they would have
it appears if they
if they attempt to inflict more
suffering they think that will re that
will bring them to their end goal which
only leads to more tragedy uh but it's
been amazing to see the ukrainians fight
yeah those guests were fascinating p
dodd thanks for the update tonight
thanks for sticking around with us hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else